ça je me disais tu m'a jamais parlé de
thé ex deux peuvent parfois y ait rien
de particulier enfin je suis je suis
resté un an avec une fille comme toi et
tu penses encore règle non non mais t'es
un gros mytho quand même parce que tu
penses à moi tout le temps parce que je
te manque douche je te manque
et en plus le mieux qu'elle 1 1 tout est
mieux quand même chez moi
1 je te manque tu aimerais bien de
vendre la série thierry fort mais elle
est bien mais le shit finir son
je la tête tout le temps
ouais voilà c'était nos vacances en
tunisie on était heureux parce qu'on a
raté pas baiser vacances dans le tarn or
c'est bien fait chier du condat baiser
latéraux baiser un gars mon job
ça vous way arrête
as tu sais ce que c'est trois ans je
suis resté trois ans avec m
trois ans tu seras jamais ce que ces
trois ans on a eu un cochon d'inde
rouler dagobert au québec et tous
bourrés terry qu large histoire
qu'est ce que tu crois bien sûr qu'il
l'apaiser
faux